you work is this right you worked with
Fred Savage from The Wonder Years who is
now of course so grown into quite a nice
adult yeah but you worked with him on
friends with college friends from
college
yes and I play Fred savages boyfriend on
that show and it's so surreal because if
anyone had to like so many people I
watched The Wonder Years religiously
with my parents as a kid and if someone
had told me when I was watching that
show when I was like 12 years old okay
one day you are going to work with Fred
Savage and you are going to play his gay
lover people told you in front of your
parents and so but it was great and Fred
did this very cute thing where I think
when we started doing you know he really
wanted to let me know he was okay you
know playing a gay guy and we were
playing out like sort of a long-term
couple so he would throw in all these
like kisses that weren't written in the
script and he kept like kissing me which
was on one on the one hand very cute on
the other hand I was like stop touching
me I get it
like I get it he was overcome it sounds
like he was overcompensating yeah yes
but in a very sweet well and you weren't
even rehearsing or shooting a show at
the time like gay Winnie Cooper though
so it was really
you